hi everybody this is Karol G I'm at
BuzzFeed and we're gonna read some
thirst tweets I am so nervous about
let's do it
[Music]
I love Carol G accent I want her to read
me a bedtime story every night Mamacita
area
I don't even want to be famous for the
money or anything I just want to be able
to attempt to a slide encourages DM okay
boy I'm gonna look at you on Twitter and
I'm going to gonna send you some
pictures of how my DMs look like okay
Carol G race car never declines
I have a pressure to do my best face
card in my life looking at the camera so
that's why I don't want to look at it
Karol G literally my fantasy in human
form she's all got them gorgeous whoa
okay I so embarrassed reading those
twists karogi is my actual Queen I don't
talk about her enough but her songs
slap like she's a goddess okay
that's one of the most important things
in my life no matter how I look no
matter how like what I wear I just want
you to listen to my music and feel happy
and feel something and get inspired by
it or whatever but that makes you feel
this like I'm super happy and I'm doing
cuddle juice but it's hard
thank you I don't know what to say like
I really work hard for that on the gym
so thank you so much for that accomplish
he's gonna like I'm gonna keep doing I
would allow Karol G to and meet with her
okay
my God people you on Twitter are like
you're crazy I don't know if I want kind
of YouTube for me or I want just one to
be here what can I say maybe you could
love both took some time to listen to
karanji and wow I love this plus she has
nice boobs so it doesn't Blues
oh my God what can I say okay I can
share a little bit of of the Boost
because I have it like a little discover
today I think you're enjoying this side
of the picture
number 10.
what the
I'm so wet over Carol this Grammy
performance okay I get it I'm good with
it I just want to bite out of this ass
that said that's the tweet
should I just stand up and just show no
of course not so thank you for the
completement lucky one Carol G to top me
oh
I can look good in that one too with
this hair I will look amazing for sure I
will let karolita's love me that woman
kept wingly dominate me who chooses do
it
[Laughter]
oh it's just with this sweet my God I
will go nose deep in Karol G
respectfully how you can say that
respectfully like like now my nose is a
credit card or what ah your nose is a
credit card of what because I know some
songs like that say that okay so hot I
wanna eat her butt no Twitter you have
something with my butt understand that I
need to cover it more in my pictures on
Instagram or what or maybe show it more
no I always said I will never let
anybody spit in my mouth but I do
anything just for Carol did to do it let
me tell you that if I do it I will do it
the best way the sexiest way the hardest
weight I could
so keep
Karol G deserve her ass a specialist for
her song she wrote that song okay I love
this one if I deserve that I just
I just can't say that uh no I'm not
gonna say that
I was in something that I'm not gonna
I can tell you that I got what I
deserved
Carol G could ask me to lick her toilet
and I would if I get just one toilet for
me and nobody uses I'm gonna let you
know for sure to lick it Karol G is so
fine I wanna eat that
oh my God you gave me a crazy idea for a
song I will let Karol g pack just make
improvements that that song is cocaine
yeah
okay so I let garage pack for making up
oh that's something that I haven't tried
now I want to do it I ain't gonna cup I
let karogi no it's for my chest is
I could do better if I just sit and
dance you're gonna love it better than
this okay I think I need a little
recovery after this because you have
like I don't know what you have in those
Minds uh but thank you so much if you
think I'm pretty and if you like my
music of course and remember that my
album my new album is out so go and
check it out ciao
[Music]
stop